це вулиця Чайковського от бачимо вона
повністю затоплена і проходити Тут можна
тільки в гумових чоботах всюди де
з'являється русский мир е немає там
ніякого щейковського Пушкіна
Достоєвського Толстого там є тільки
руйнування і смерть І власне це є
обличчя не навмисного абсолютно люди
ненависницького Русского Мира це
корабельна площа Херсона де в перші дні
після підриву каховської ГЕС рівень води
піднявся от до кінця оцих залізних
споруд Саме тут сьогодні починається
затоплена частина міста і досі от острів
там вода досягає приблизно 4-5 метрів
води і наша доблесні рятувальники зі
служби надзвичайних ситуацій наша
поліцейські чергують тут для того щоб
надавати людям першу допомогу для того
щоб евакуювати людей і сьогодні двоє
людей було евакуйовано евакуювати тварин
готівку кататися
така є ось бачимо Вона злякана бідна
перелякана це Отакі
от така маленька Отже тут знаходиться
штаб працює
зведених загонів всіх підрозділів ДСНС
України які виконують основні завдання
спрямовані на порятунок людей та надання
допомоги
постражданню ми бачимо тут комп'ютери ми
бачимо тут ваших колег яка інформація
сюди стікається будь-яка інформація
стосовно необхідності надання допомоги
на себе яка взагалі безпекова і
гуманітарна екологічна
ситуація
все буде в Україні на сьогоднішній день
є дощ хмари Вона не дає вдобства
працювати на воді але вона надає
працювати агресору
по нам на потязі трьох днів проводились
обстріли і працювали люди
урахуванням безпеки особового складу а
також безпеки тих людей кому надається
допомога сьогодні було встановлено за
допомогою місцевої влади пункти у
вигляді укриття для особового складу
який так і населення які
забезпечують рятувальні роботи за цей
час нашим
рятувальникам нашим поліціантам вдалося
евакуювати більше
2,700 людей і Ми дякуємо справжнім
Героям цієї війни рятувальникам і тим
хто допомагає евакуювати людей вода
потроху спускається а люди які от на цих
вулицях залишаються в своїх домівках
хтось не хоче виїжджати хтось хоче
врятувати будівлю і найбільш херсонці
переживають за мешканців окупованого
лівого берега тому що в олешках сьогодні
справжня Гуманітарна катастрофа ми з
Марією іоновою сьогодні в Херсоні тому
що дуже важливо не просто На власні очі
побачити як потерпає місто від цієї
техногенної катастрофи а й сформулювати
і сформувати той пакет який треба
передати нашим міжнародним партнерам для
гуманітарної інфологічної допомоги
України показують фотографії не тільки
прильоту але я питаю про евакуацію людей
тобто оголошення дуже багато людей не
хочуть
евакуйовуватися і
якраз пан командир він спілкується
вмовляє особливо з літніми людьми що
дуже важливо
переїхати на
ту територію там де буде безпечно там де
буде вода електрика їжа і харчування але
люди бояться теж залишати свої місця
перебираються на поверх і вище Але знову
ж таки людяність координація спілкування
тобто роблять наші служби все що
можливості врятувати цивільних людей
Вони командири за сім днів Скільки ви
особисто врятували дітей евакуювали
людей ну особисто як керував дію
Особисто я ну двох осіб але це спільна
праця Як волонтерів так її представників
національної поліції а також не дають
допомогу
представники збройних сил України у
понеділок відбудеться тут пояснення
засідання комітету екології для того щоб
почати вивчати на місці
яку я би місце і
взагалі регіону нанесла Гуманітарна
катастрофа але вже зараз можна говорити
що вода повністю спуститься десь за 10
днів на два тижні це тільки після цього
буде зрозуміло масштаби катастро а що
нам сьогодні неофіційно вже говорять
керівники причетні до евакуації що
скільки буде мору риби і тварин на жаль
на підтоплених окупованих територіях що
тут будуть потрібні навіть мобільні
крематорії саме для того щоб утилізувати
тварин які на жаль загинули Ну і
очевидно що наша мета як політиків Наша
задача зробити все для того щоб Путін
такий режим цей Злочинний режим було
притягнуто до відповідальності за екоцид
за геноцид українського народу має бути
Путін і його банда покарання це Херсон
Херсон незламний і наші люди
демонструють тут ну абсолютно унікальні
якості людяності взаємодопомоги і
солідарності тому ми точно переможемо
все буде Україна
100%. ми тут кота врятували Так Він в
нас є в клітці